[Music]
welcome back in an exclusive interview
Boeing's chief executive tells CBS News
he's sorry about two deadly crashes
involving Boeing 737 max airliner Dennis
Muhlenberg says the company is learning
from the accidents and vows to make
improvements that includes updating
software on the planes that he says will
make the 737 max among the safest
airplanes ever to fly newly announced
CBS Evening News anchor Norah O'Donnell
spoke to Muhlenberg Nora good morning
welcome back thank you did you know how
to find the room I did know how to find
you like yeah this was a fascinating
interview Muhlenberg is taking
responsibility man knows he has work to
do in regaining public trust the Boeing
737 max has been grounded around the
world since March of this year following
those crashes in Ethiopia and Indonesia
that killed 346 passengers and crew when
you heard that a second plane had
crashed the same type of plane what went
through your mind this gets to the core
of who we are as a company you know I've
been at Boeing for 34 years and I've
spent a career working on safe products
we paused we assess the situation we
immediately began to take actions on
what we could do to improve and in the
end this reinforces our values as a
company do you think it would be
appropriate to apologize personally
apologize to some of the families yeah I
do personally apologize to the families
I can tell you it affects me directly as
a leader of this company it's very
difficult now so you know we can't
change what happened in these accidents
but we can be absolutely resolute in
what we're going to do on safety you put
your family on a 737 max without any
hesitation absolutely I've been up on
two of the flight tests myself with the
new software and I would in a heartbeat
put my family on max
what do you say to someone in the flying
public who says I am not comfortable
getting on a Boeing 737 max we know it
will take some time to earn and riyer
n-- that public confidence and the first
step will be to get the max back up and
flying safely flight 610 that crashed
into the Java Sea about 12 minutes after
takeoff killed a hundred and eighty-nine
people on board what's your
understanding of what brought that
flight down we know that there was
inaccurate sensor data that came into
the airplane that there appears to have
been a maintenance issue with that
sensor we know that the EM cast software
was activated multiple times during that
flight it was more than multiple times
it was two dozen times according to the
data released in this preliminary crash
report the pilots were essentially in a
tug of war with the plane and that plane
essentially did a death dive into the
ocean at 450 miles an hour can you
imagine how terrifying that was for the
people on board we examine every
dimension of these accidents not to try
to attribute fault or or point fingers
but it's to understand and and what
happened so that in some cases we can
make changes to the airplane design to
make it safer both of these planes took
a nosedive because of that erroneous
flight sensor information and if one of
the sensors is off it's my understanding
that there could be a warning light but
that light was supposed to be active on
all 737 max Jets and it was not you knew
this in 2017 and you did not tell the
FAA for 13 months why the the
implementation of that software we did
not do it correctly
our engineers discovered that so you're
fixing that now we're fixing it now and
in our communication on that was not
what it should have been
does Boeing have a credibility and
transparency problem if they don't admit
what were the mistakes in the past we
clearly fell short and and the
implementation of this angle-of-attack
disagree alert was a mistake in the
weeks
after the first crash there were pilots
who met with one of your vice presidents
Mike sunette a lot of pilots who said we
didn't know about this and caste system
yeah yeah inset they blamed Boeing yeah
and we respect we should respect that
input
I'll never shy away from from pilot
commentary in fact I prefer that hard
candid feedback I think it's good it's
good for us it makes us a better company
and in the end it makes for safety in
flight that's pretty strong Nora how
does Boeing's bottom line do we think
factor into his admission now that
they've made mistakes well he says look
safety is their number-one priority
that's a value of the company but it's
clear that it's costing this company a
lot of money 737 is its most profitable
and one of its most popular planes and
one of things he said they're gonna be a
hundred and fifty million new customers
in Asia every year flying flying
customers and they like that market
likes the 737 Boeing is a great American
company right it leads the Dow many
times which is the Dow Ford so but
they're doing everything they've they
finished this software fix that we
talked about they submitted it to the
FAA they're waiting for the FAA approval
it could come as soon as this month that
those planes are back up the air but I
think what you heard him say it
acknowledged for the first time a change
in tone is that this has damaged public
trust confidence in Florida that the
issue to that issue do you think Boeing
would would even consider rebranding
this plane effectively well as you know
the president Trump suggested that in a
tweet that and so I asked Muhlenberg
about this and he said this is not a
rebranding issue this is a safety issue
so no plans to rebrand the plane I think
it's good that he spoke up everybody
that knows him says that he's a really
good CEO but I was curious about his
demeanor Nora off camera because on
camera he seems so clinical to me and
dare I say a tad distant considering the
pain that this accident these two
accidents have caused can you tell us
anything about him
I mean he is you know dyed-in-the-wool
kind of Boeing employee he started he's
an ayat from an Iowa farm boy you know
who started off as an intern and 34
years later made his way up to CEO so I
think he cares deeply about that he's a
he's been walking the halls but you can
he's a big-time CEO they do a lot of
defense work so he is buttoned up and so
there was a change in tone in him
talking about personally apologizing to
these families he says it's been the
most challenging part of his entire
career I appreciate him talking to you
yeah or interviews like that right here
at the table no nor walked in the room
and said I'm back I have something for
you two on Monday always good to see you
you can hear more of Nora's interview
with Boeing CEO Dennis Muhlenberg on
today's CBS this morning podcast